-Our first guest tonight
is an actor and comedian
you know best
from the "Jackass" franchise.
New episodes from
his show "Reboot"
are available to stream
Tuesdays on Hulu.
Let's take a look.
-Hey, Jared, you got a sec?
-Yeah, what's up?
-Uh, I'm in AA,
and I'm supposed to make amends
with people I might
have wronged, you know,
back when I was overdoing it?
-Must be a hell of a list.
-Yeah.
And since you're here,
thought I might as well
pop my cherry with you.
-Yeah, okay.
I'll try to be gentle.
-Back then,
I either came to work drunk,
stoned, or hung over.
I can't even remember
Season Three. [ Chuckles ]
But shouldn't have done it.
Filled with regrets.
Uh, blah, blah, blah.
-Well, Clay, thanks
for those heartfelt words.
-Good.
-Okay, boys! Take him up!
-Please welcome to the show,
our friend, Johnny Knoxville,
everybody!
[ Cheers and applause ]
♪♪
-Hello!
-I'm really happy
to have you here.
I was also really happy to
hear you on the wonderful
Dana Carvey,
David Spade podcast.
You came clean about
something you did to me
when you hosted "SNL" in 2005.
-Accidentally did to you.
-I do not --
We have video proof here.
-Okay, let's --
-First, I want to show this.
This is your monologue.
I want to show people
how it was written.
This is how it was written
for the actual night.
It goes, "Seth comes on stage,
tackles Johnny, and then --"
Sorry, here's where it is.
This is the important thing.
"System of a Down is here,
so stick around,
we'll be right back.
Then Seth hits
Johnny in the nuts."
That's how it was scripted.
-That's how it was scripted.
And I never got a chance
to apologize to you
on national TV
for misreading the card.
-Okay.
-Yeah.
-So that's the accident, is
you misread Wally's cards?
-Yes, I got the words -- Yeah.
-Okay, because I think you'll
see by watching this clip
that it also
caught me off guard.
Let's take a look.
-There you have it.
That's how my week has been.
I'm not complaining.
I'm hosting
"Saturday Night Live."
We got a great show --
Oh!
Great show tonight, yeah!
-Yeah.
-System of a Down is here.
-Oh!
-Stick around,
we'll be right back!
[ Cheers and applause ]
-I'm laughing,
but I'm hurting inside.
Because I did not mean
to do that.
-Well, I hadn't watched
that clip since then.
And when I watched it,
I hurt inside.
-It was a solid shot.
-It was a real solid shot.
-I don't want to get graphic,
but I felt the whole outline of
your business on my hand.
And, you know --
-Yeah.
-He's packing some lumber.
-Yeah, I will say, I really --
when I fell down,
I both felt intense pain,
but I will say, part of my brain
thought, "He's one of the best."
[ Laughter ]
He's one of the best
that ever did it.
-We had to go right into
the next scene, though.
-Yeah.
-You were in such pain.
[ Laughter ]
I felt almost terrible.
-You were really
torn up about it.
Congratulations.
So this is a very novel take
on a phenomenon that's been
happening a lot
in the last decade-plus, about
rebooting classic sitcoms.
But this is
a really cool take on it.
How would you explain "Reboot?"
-Well, it's a show about a show.
The main characters,
we all get a chance --
we didn't get along
when we first made the show.
It was like a "Family Ties" type
of -- not "Family Ties."
-Like, "Family Matters."
-A "Full House" type of show.
And then we get a chance 15
years later to remake the show.
And we all have our things,
our obstacles.
Picture this --
I play a naughty comedian
who has overdone it in his past.
-[ Laughter ] Uh-huh?
-Maybe drank a little
too much at times.
-Yeah, yeah, yeah.
A stretch, as it's known
in the acting biz.
-A stretch.
[ Laughter ]
But I'm just trying to
do the best I can.
Like,
every character on the show
is trying to do
the best they can,
but we kind of get in
our own ways.
-I was mentioning this,
Steve-O was here recently,
and I was talking about
the last "Jackass" movie.
It affected me in a way
that I didn't think it would.
I thought it was really funny,
but I also, I felt nostalgic.
It was genuinely emotional
to see so many of you
still doing it
all these years later.
Does it feel that way
when you're together?
-First of all, thank you.
And yeah, it does feel pretty
wonderful when we're together.
I mean, it's nerve-racking
and a lot of things.
But I mean, we've been
friends for 20 years,
and we created something that
grew into whatever it is.
And yeah. It's special.
-It's cool to -- I mean, nothing
sort of endures that long.
I think it reminds
a lot of people about
their friend groups, which are
sort of lovingly idiotic.
-Yeah.
-And that comes across
all the time.
-Sure, everyone did
silly things like this
growing up with their friends.
-We just didn't think
to monetize it.
[ Laughter ]
-Yeah.
-I know you've got kids.
You've got some younger kids.
Do they find their way
to "Jackass?"
When do they -- I can't imagine
you show to it them.
-Okay, no.
Their friends have seen it.
-Right.
-And I think out of
their friend group,
my kids have seen it the least.
Like, I'll show them,
as far as I know,
I'll show them a bit
here and there.
But nothing naughty,
or nothing where Daddy gets
knocked out, you know?
-Yeah.
-So my oldest daughter,
she was 14 when I let her
go to the "Jackass 3D" premiere,
and she had to sit
right next to me.
And I'm like, "Baby, you have to
close your eyes at some parts,
close your ears in others,
and close both in..." you know?
And she did.
-She did?
-Yeah.
And plus, my son is --
The girls are smart, right?
And Rocco's smart, but he's,
like, a little excitable.
-Yeah.
-And he wants to do that stuff,
and I let him know that's
not really going to happen.
-I mean, I can't imagine.
Because I'm always
telling my kids,
"Don't do that. It's dangerous."
But I got to imagine it's
so empty coming from you.
[ Laughter ]
-No, no, no --
Well, okay, that's fair.
[ Laughter ]
If they crack
a joke or something,
if it's a little on the line,
I'm like, "That's alright."
-Yeah.
-But I remember when they
were real little,
I was a helicopter parent.
-Yeah.
-At the playground, because
I don't want them to get hurt.
-Yeah, I would imagine, right.
-I was -- yeah.
I don't know if
it makes sense, but --
-I think it does make sense.
Certainly, you know
the repercussions.
I would just say, I hope that
they don't make the mistake
that I made, and trust you.
[ Laughter ]
-God forbid they trust
their father.
[ Cheers and applause ]
-Thank you so much
for being here.
-Thank you.
-It is always such a delight
to see you, old friend.
Johnny Knoxville!
New episodes of "Reboot"
available to stream
Tuesdays on Hulu.
We'll be right back
with Jake Lacy.